voilà ce stade du journal et c'est
vraiment la fin nous voudrions élevé une
protestation qui a très peu de chances
d'être entendus car je ne sais pas trop
comment nous reçoit là haut je veux
parler du temps nous sommes très
précisément le 15 juin
à six jours de l'été et tout se détraque
un mois de mai pour y un début juin qui
promet mais depuis une semaine des
températures anormalement basses alors
aujourd'hui encore de la pluie sur la
région parisienne
des orages dans le sud et en montagne
bref ça ne va pas et on a envie de
savoir ce que nous réserve le week-end à
venir alors d'abord le constat laurent
broomhead et bien effectivement il ya
une période de boutons en nacre entité
le mois d'août est malheureusement comme
c'est normal au mois de juin
il ya du mauvais temps une zone de
mauvais temps qui s'est déclenché au
nord de l'islande et quitte
tranquillement des sceaux il va passer
au nord de la france pendant le week-end
elle va amener des perturbations
successives en flot continu alors
concrètement qu'est ce que ça veut dire
pour demain alors demain vendredi
ma demain la première vague celle qui
arrose paris en ce moment elle va être
sur l'est depuis le jura le jura jusqu'à
l'alsace derrière ben y aura des airs
plus éclairci belle normal
et puis derrière malheureusement ça
c'est ennuyeux il va y avoir une poussée
d'une deuxième vague de mauvais temps
beaucoup plus virulent et dans toute la
journée elle va envahir toute la france
attention rafale de ventes pour les
plaisanciers dans le golfe de gascogne
ça signifie pour ceux qui partent en
week end et bien ma foi il faut prendre
les parapluies faut prendre les
imperméables et le samedi sera pas très
bon et nous ont alors le samedi ça veut
dire plus gai le temps sera frais sur
toute la france les températures vont
encore baisser
il y aura des averses des orages sur à
peu près toute la france tout de même
kit note d'optimiste sur le sud sur la
moitié sud quelques belles éclaircies
en conclusion peut espérer pour dimanche
on peut espérer que les éclaircies
l'emporteront sur mauvais temps enfin en
tout état de cause cette mosquée al
azhar révélé un week-end vraiment
maussade gars n'avaient pas intérêt à
vous trompez car à partir d'aujourd'hui
vous êtes notre monsieur 29 monsieur
météo tout court donc décidé de mettre
davantage l'accent sur les prévisions du
temps et d'être si possible meilleur que
les autres
vous reviendrez nous voir donc avant
chaque week-end et puis à chaque fois
que l'actualité l'obligent et si
possible en tout cas le jeudi soir